well biases are one of the most
interesting phenomena in evolution and I
would go as far as saying there's
nothing that's not a bias
I mean we're biased to live in a certain
temperature range and we prefer sweet
food to a over a bit of food so biases
are essential they really guide us in a
broader sense so that we that we don't
hurt ourselves you know a bias towards
feeling solid ground rather than
wobbling ground the interesting thing is
really not to try to do away with these
biases but to really recognize them and
not to see them as something negative
and yet to really understand that
they're cloud or clear thinking and you
know that goes anywhere from
self-deception to uniqueness bias that
we think and pay and one of the first
one to think I'm very unique and you
know basically the brain evolved for us
to make ourselves special to think of us
as valuable otherwise we would not be
able to go through the strains and the
struggles and difficulties of life so
bias is in any case negativity bias
positive bias confirmation bias all of
these are so ingrained in us that we
don't even see them they are kind of
transparent for us so the way that I
like to look at it is the more we can
detect them and become aware of it it's
it's kind of a hide and seek you know
they come out of left field and the more
we can become aware of them and discover
them it's actually quite amusing how we
twist reality in a way that confirms our
particular view of the world and so I
don't see them as something that's
obstructing a healthy good positive life
but it narrows the window and the more
we become aware of
the broader we can approach and the
closer we can get to reality
well confirmation bias is probably one
of the most pronounced biases that we
have and anybody who has ever bought a
car and thought for a while about what
kind of car they want to buy they
probably noticed suddenly oh yeah
there's that car there's that car again
and suddenly the brain kind of detects
in the environment something that
confirms like oh yes that's that seems
like a really good car so confirmation
bias is really a way for us to reaffirm
our view of the world and to some degree
it's actually essential if we didn't
have some kind of confirmation bias we
would be lost
we could not piece together a world that
is coherent for us so we have to ignore
certain things and other things become a
little louder and confirmation bias is
different in different cultures you know
for some cultures in a big broad
shouldered person is very attractive and
in others it's a very elegant person or
a very lively person and you know and I
come from Germany so in Germany the
confirmation bias is towards don't make
a mistake you know get everything proper
and order and get it right so
confirmation bias is really essential
and yet it's really valuable to
recognize that what we perceive and how
we view it as completely twisted by our
internal biases I believe the value in
becoming aware of biases is that it
gives you the opportunity of having a
little larger perspective the danger of
not being aware of it that we think we
are right so the value in understanding
confirmation biases is that when we are
in some kind of discussion or when we go
into a different culture that we
recognize you know the world looks
different for other people and it's not
that mine is right or better or theirs
is right or better and I cannot really
force them to see it my way
and they cannot force me to see it their
way so recognizing that confirmation
bias is completely ingrained allows us
to chuckle sometimes you know when we
kind of insist on a particular way of
seeing the world whether it's
politically or whether it's social it's
very important it allows us to actually
listen to other people better and drop
the confirmation bias maybe for a moment
there's not any particular bias that I
would recognize it's more important than
the other but I do find the uniqueness
buyers especially amusing you know that
that we consider ourselves to be unique
and the the reason I believe that we
have a uniqueness bias is that we're the
only person that we are with 24 hours a
day so we have far more information
about ourselves about our bodies about
our history about our capacities so it
takes a much much more space in our
inner universe so to say and because we
have so much more detail about our
selves and our own lives it looms much
larger than anybody else so the
interesting thing about uniqueness bias
is that it's not just about ourselves
but their circles of uniqueness for
instance we consider our person that we
have a relationship with as more unique
than other people because we know more
about them we consider our parents of
more unique than or our siblings again
because we know so much more about them
and if you get to know somebody then
they become more unique than other
people you know my friends are really
more unique than other people's friends
you know or they're more special I'm
closer to them and it really I believe
depends all on how much information we
have about them and how important
they're in our lives
you